mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer nous sommes heureux madame la
ministre de vous accueillir pour cette
audition devant notre commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
Communication c'est la deuxième fois que
nous avons la possibilité d'échanger
avec vous puisque vous étiez déjà venu
au Sénat le 1er juin dernier je crois
que c'était dans cette salle tu restes
avec votre collègue le ministre de
l'Intérieur pour évoquer les événements
intervenus lors de la finale de la
Champions League au Stade de France
quelque sorte c'était un baptême du feu
un peu particulier pour vous et nous
aurons l'occasion de vous réauditionner
dans dans quelques jours ce sera le de
nouveau le 2 novembre sur les crédits de
votre ministère dans le
cadre bien sûr du projet de loi de
finances
pour 2023 l'audition de ce jour vise à
vous donner l'occasion de présenter
votre feuille de route au-delà de la loi
de finance et de rentrer peut-être plus
dans le détail de certaines
actions que vous souhaitez et que vous
avez commencé à entreprendre nous nous
réjouissons tout d'abord que le ministre
terre des sports soit redevenu à un
ministère de plein exercice c'était une
attente forte de notre assemblée
plusieurs fois évoquée nous souhaitons
maintenant vous entendre sur vos
priorités à moins de deux ans des Jeux
Olympiques et
paralympique de Paris 2024 dans un
contexte qui ne cesse d'évoluer et de
rencontrer des difficultés nouvelles je
pense bien évidemment au conflit du aux
conséquences du conflit en Ukraine
et de des conséquences économiques
notamment à travers la hausse de
l'inflation mais également des
conditions en termes de sécurité nous
auditionnerons la semaine prochaine le
ministre de l'intérieur avec nos
collègues de la commission des lois sur
ces questions de sécurité et de jeux
olympiques mais nous serions évidemment
intéressés par le fait de connaître
votre sentiment sur ce point dès
aujourd'hui car il ne nous semble pas
que toutes les leçons des événements du
Stade de France étaient tirés en termes
de réorganisation peut-être également
pourrez-vous nous préciser le contour de
du futur projet de loi sur lequel vous
travaillez avec la dijob concernant
certaines mesures qui seraient plutôt
techniques relative à la préparation des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques si vous
pouvez nous préciser évidemment le
calendrier et le périmètre de ce texte
nous serions
nous en serions très reconnaissants vous
aborderons évidemment les questions
liées à un certain nombre d'affaires qui
sont survenues ces dernières semaines je
pense aux tensions au sein du CNSF
à l'affaire de justice en cours au qui
concerne des dirigeants de la Fédération
française de rugby mais aussi des
événements au sein de la Fédération
française de football qui vous préoccupe
qui nous préoccupe
alors même que notre pays s'apprête à
accueillir deux grands événements
sportifs dans la ministre je vais vous
céder la parole pour un propos liminaire
d'une quinzaine de minutes et ensuite
nous vous poserons des questions pour
que cet échange soit le plus animé
possible et le plus que les discussions
soient les plus directes possibles ce
sera notre rapporteur pour avis des
crédits budgétaires à savoir
Jean-Jacques luzot loza qui vous posera
les les premières questions il sera
suivi par les deux rapporteurs des
missions d'information relatives aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
David Assouline puis bien sûr chacun
d'entre vous pourra s'exprimer par la
suite madame la ministre sans plus
tarder je vous donne la parole
monsieur le Président chers
monsieur le rapporteur cher Jean-Jacques
Lauzac mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je tiens tout d'abord à vous à
vous remercier pour votre invitation à
m'exprimer devant votre commission
ce qui me donne l'opportunité d'exposer
devant vous les enjeux relatifs au sport
à sa gouvernance
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
à la façon dont collectivement nous
pouvons parvenir à inscrire davantage
l'activité physique et sportive au cœur
de notre société au cœur de notre
jeunesse au cœur de notre approche de la
prévention de la santé du bien-être de
nos concitoyens qui ont besoin à une
heure où la sédentarité civile la
prégnance des écrans et partout dans
notre quotidien de trouver de puiser
dans le sport une source
d'épanouissement pour certains une
source d'émancipation pour d'autres de
renforcement de leur confiance en
eux-mêmes
l'État assume de longue date évidemment
un rôle stratégique en matière de
politique du sport la création de
l'Agence nationale du sport en 2019 a
marqué une évolution importante dans ce
modèle je pense que nous aurons des
échanges sur les conclusions que nous
devons en tirer dans les équilibres
politiques institution stratégique de
notre sport français et bien entendu
penser pour les collectivités
territoriales qui aujourd'hui consacrent
la majorité des investissements en
matière de sport en matière d'équipement
sportifs notamment et qui sont bien
évidemment au cœur de nos politiques
publiques sportives
peut-être trois temps dans cette exposée
introductif d'abord évoquer
l'enjeu premier de la réussite de notre
très grands événements sportifs
internationaux bien évidemment les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques mais
peut-être aussi un mot sur la Coupe du
monde de rugby qui marquera son coup
d'envoi le 8 septembre 2023
dans un second temps je voudrais évoquer
peut-être les axes prioritaires de la
fortification nécessaire de notre modèle
sportif en France avant de revenir sur
la dimension plus sociétale de l'impact
que nous cherchons à avoir à travers le
développement de la pratique sportive
sur le premier point celui des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques je
paralympiques que nos accueillerons pour
la première fois de notre histoire en
France j'ai coutume de dire qu'il s'agit
de réunir un carré magique d'exigence
d'abord délivrer l'organisation la plus
irréprochable possible sur le plan
sportif nous avons en tête nos 54
disciplines nos 879 épreuves mais aussi
bien entendu sur les enjeux de sécurité
avec une soixantaine de sites à
sécuriser les cérémonies d'ouverture en
dehors du stade a réussi et un besoin de
l'ordre de 22000 agents de sécurité
privée par jour au pic de ses besoins un
enjeu également en matière de transport
nous avons en tête qu'il s'agira de
véhiculer de transporter d'acheminer 800
000 personnes quotidiennement sur
l'ensemble des sites de compétition dont
200 000 accrédités en jeu logistique à
travers les services de restauration les
capacités d'hébergement les 20 000
journalistes et 260 000 à crédités
globale qui seront attendus sur notre
événement et bien entendu réussir aussi
notre pari sur le plan d'une forme
d'exemplarité écologique avec la
réduction par deux de nos émissions et
les premiers jeux écologiques capables
de porter une signature qui sera celle
d'une neutralité carbone grâce à des
investissements dans des projets à
impact positif et de soutien à la
biodiversité et le dernier enjeu non des
moindres celui de la maîtrise de nos
budgets continuer de faire en sorte que
les jeux financent les jeux que nous
sachions contenir l'impact de
l'inflation préservée d'équilibre des
dépenses et des recettes pour être au
rendez-vous de cet enjeu budgétaire qui
est au cœur évidemment
de l'acceptabilité sociale pour les
Français de notre grande événement
la deuxième grande dimension pour
réussir ce carré magique d'objectifs
c'est d'aider nos athlètes à être au
meilleur de leur performances jouer à
domicile ça met du vent dans les voiles
c'est aussi parfois source de pression
il faudra que nous les entourions de
toute la sérénité nécessaire de tout
l'accompagnement technique
médical mental pour leur permettre
d'être à l'heure pour ce grand
rendez-vous dans un moment où le sport
français a plutôt eu de bons résultats
depuis l'été les Jeux de Munich en
matière d'athlétisme les bons résultats
en matière de cyclisme également
récemment qui doivent nous encourager
également sur le plan de l'Escrime qui a
pu briller au mondiaux d'Égypte le
deuxième pardon le troisième grand enjeu
de ce carré magique c'est d'arriver à
faire de ces jeux une source
d'engouement populaire et même une fête
pour l'ensemble des français ce qui
supposera de continuer à animer la
montée en puissance vers les jeux qui
sera également marquée de grands moments
comme le relais de la flamme et au-delà
de faire vivre dans l'ensemble des
territoires le label terre de jeux les
clubs 2024 qui seront ces zones de
célébration autour de l'événement aussi
faire monter en puissance la présence de
cet événement dans l'enceinte de l'école
à travers la Semaine Olympique et
paralympique qui aura lieu en avril
prochain autour du thème de l'inclusion
voilà quelques exemples vous avez suivi
que samedi dernier nous avions la
première journée paralympique pour
mettre à l'honneur l'ensemble des
paraports qui s'inscrit dans ce qui est
le quatrième
coin de ce carré magique la nécessité de
laisser un héritage
utile durable pour le pays tant sur le
plan matériel avec notamment
l'investissement vraiment fait pour la
Seine-Saint-Denis le département à la
fois le plus pauvre et le plus jeune de
France qui consacre 80% des sommes
investies par la solideo avec un grand
projet de construction
de porter là aussi assez exemplaire sur
le plan écologique et qui permettront de
léguer à se département 4000 logements
dont 40% de logements sociaux
héritage aussi immatériel sur le plan de
la pratique sportive pour continuer à le
diffuser au sein de notre jeunesse dans
une logique de continuité éducative de
la maternelle à l'université travailler
sur le volet des équipements travailler
sur le volet du design actif
c'est-à-dire aménager notre cadre de vie
pour qu'il soit plus propice à
l'activité du vélo de la marche mais
aussi que tout ceci favorise le moteur
que peut être le sport en termes
d'insertion professionnelle pour
l'ensemble des composantes sociales de
notre de notre pays
le deuxième grand enjeu je
l'évoquais c'est la nécessité de bien
fortifier notre modèle sportif français
aujourd'hui
et peut-être 5 points pour cela d'abord
continuer à bâtir un modèle sportif
d'excellence nous avons aujourd'hui
15000 sportifs de haut niveau dans notre
pays qui ont besoin d'être toujours
mieux accompagnés par leur fédération
par l'Agence nationale du sport et
notamment sa composante tournée vers la
haute performance autour du programme
ambition bleu
également un sport engagé un sport
engagé fort de ces 3,5 millions de
bénévoles sportifs en France
dont nous avons besoin de sécuriser la
vitalité que nous avons besoin de
rajeunir que nous avons besoin également
de féminiser c'est l'un des enjeux qui a
été porté notamment ici dans cette
enceinte autour de l'adoption de la loi
du 2 mars 2022 qui prévoit
l'instauration de la parité au niveau
des équipes dirigeantes du sport
français à l'échelon des ligues
régionales en 2028 et à l'échelon
nationale des fédérations en 2024 un
sport également
robuste doté des bons niveaux de
ressources ressources financières
j'aurais un effet l'occasion de venir me
présenter devant vous le 2 novembre pour
évoquer la préparation du projet de loi
de finances mais également sur le plan
humain le concours qu'apporte nos cadres
techniques et sportifs dont l'allocation
doit continuer de s'optimiser dans une
logique d'efficacité et d'équité au
service des fédérations des cadres de
mon ministère bien formé dont nous avons
besoin encore d'accentuer la formation
continue pour les préparer aux
évolutions de leur métier le quatrième
élément c'est un sport responsable un
sport qui le soit sous l'angle de
l'éthique de l'intégrité
un sport capable de prévenir toutes les
formes de violence violence dans les
stades violences dans la société
notamment à caractère sexiste ou sexuel
mais aussi un sport responsable dans sa
transition écologique avec la nécessité
d'embrasser pleinement notre engagement
sur la sobriété énergétique j'aurais
l'opportunité demain de réunir
l'ensemble des acteurs du sport pour
contracter de notre plan détaillé de
sobriété énergétique mais au-delà de ça
de continuer à s'inscrire dans la
continuité de la Charte des 15
engagements éco-responsables pour
travailler sur l'ensemble des dimensions
du modèle des grands événements sportifs
et des événements de moindre envergure
mais aussi de l'ensemble des instances
du sport français en matière d'énergie
renouvelable de lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire de qualité de
l'utilisation de nos ressources et de
l'eau en particulier
le dernier point de cette fortification
du modèle sportif français c'est la
nécessité de bâtir aussi un sport
influent qui porte haut en Europe et
dans le monde nos valeurs nos valeurs
françaises nos valeurs européennes ce
modèle sportif européen spécifique dont
il faut préserver la capacité à créer
ces traits d'union bien spécifiques
entre le sport amateur et le sport
professionnel et j'ai pu relancer hier
matin ce que ma prédécesseur avait mis
en place la french sport touch c'est à
dire une instance de coordination qui
vise à améliorer l'impact de notre pays
en matière sportive à l'internationale
de mieux soutenir nos entreprises dans
leur expansion et le rayonnement de leur
savoir-faire sur les grands événements
sportifs et internationaux mais aussi
d'aider à une meilleure présence de nos
nationaux dans les instances
internationales du sport
peut-être un dernier rangée celui de
bien faire pénétrer notre sport au cœur
de la société j'évoquais ce continuum
éducatif de la maternelle à l'université
vous nous savez engagé dans la
généralisation des 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidiennes pour les 6,5
millions d'élèves dans nos presque 50
000 écoles primaires à travers le
territoire la construction à laquelle
nous nous livrons en ce moment de
l'accès à deux heures supplémentaires de
sport par semaine pour nos collégiens
dans le cadre périscolaire un
aménagement que nous mettons au point en
synergie avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale mais aussi avec
les collectivités territoriales avec le
mouvement sportif et avec les chefs
d'établissement ainsi que les parents
d'élèves la reconduction et
l'élargissement de notre passeport cette
allocation de 50 euros que nous avons
choisi d'étendre cette année aux
étudiants boursiers c'est 800 000
étudiants marqués aujourd'hui par une
forme de précarité et avec l'objectif
d'étendre rapidement à plus de 2
millions de jeunes dans notre pays y
compris des jeunes en situation de
handicap le bénéfice de cette prestation
qui leur permet de prendre une
cotisation ou une licence dans un club
sportif dans l'un de nos 180 000 clubs
sportifs le développement de la pratique
étudiante au cœur de l'université sera
également au cœur de nos efforts avec
une mission que j'ai pu diligenter avec
ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau de
l'inspection générale de l'éducation du
sport et de la recherche pour
identifier et lever l'ensemble des
freins à la pratique étudiante dans un
contexte nous savons que 70% de nos
étudiants aspirent à faire du sport plus
régulièrement mais seulement 20% d'entre
eux souvent dans les établissements les
plus dotés y parviennent
sur le plan de la santé nous sommes dans
un moment où le coût de la sédentarité
est évalué à 17 milliards d'euros nous
avons avec François Braun entrepris de
bâtir ensemble une feuille de route pour
continuer à promouvoir le sport santé
continuer à promouvoir les
expérimentations prévues par l'article
51 loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et qui par exemple pour une
expérimentation qui touche aux enfants
la lutte contre l'obésité infantile qui
s'appelle retrouve ton cap et dans un
mouvement de généralisation prometteur
aujourd'hui cet engagement en faveur de
la santé et du bien-être de nos
concitoyens par le sport il se prolonge
en milieu professionnel nous savons
aujourd'hui que seulement 13% des
salariés sont en capacité sur leur lieu
de travail de faire une activité
physique et sportive c'est un
pourcentage que nous voulons faire
monter en puissance au moins jusqu'à 24
25% à l'horizon de deux ou trois ans
c'est un objectif que nous partageons
que nous portons avec les représentants
syndicaux
également la nécessité pour les
personnes malades maladies chroniques
affection de longue durée de tirer
pleinement partie du sport sur
ordonnance qui a été étendu par la loi
du 2 mars 2022 et de consolider aussi à
travers les territoires le réseau des
maisons du sport santé un dernier mot
sur ce registre de l'activité physique
et de son impact sur la santé la volonté
que nous avons avec François Brown
d'inscrire au cœur des bilans d'activité
physique pardon des bilans de santé
gratuit à 25 45 et 65 ans la dimension
d'activité physique pour bien la
surveiller et donner des conseils
appropriés à nos concitoyens s'agissant
de la pratique d'une activité physique
correspondant à leur état de forme et à
leurs aspirations sur le volet de
l'inclusion je voudrais évidemment
revaloriser le rôle social de nos clubs
sportifs qui sont souvent cette
rencontre entre une jeunesse qui a
besoin opportunités et des personnes
plus établies qui sont capables de
pouvoir des opportunités économiques
également l'engagement que nous
poursuivons en matière sportive à
travers les contrats d'engagement jeunes
à travers l'apprentissage qui a été
multipliée par 6 au cours du précédent
quinquennat également à travers des
formules comme le service civique qui
fait la preuve de son efficacité dans le
sport et que nous voulons les services
civiques génération 2024 notamment
arrivé à bien mobiliser dans le cadre de
la préparation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques je terminerai en disant
que derrière ce triptyque la réussite de
nos grands événements la fortification
de notre modèle sportif l'inscription du
sport au coeur de notre modèle de
société il y a des conditions de
réussite parmi celles-ci l'importance
d'une gouvernance du sport la plus
impeccable possible sens des efforts que
j'anime depuis le début du mois de
juillet avec l'ensemble des
représentants de notre de notre secteur
nous avons je crois et ce sera mon mot
de conclusion pour cette première
introduction à nos échanges toutes les
cartes en main pour faire et
matérialiser cette ambition que nous
portons tous je crois de faire de la
France une nation plus sportive et de
faire en sorte que partout sur les
territoires la conjugaison de nos
efforts de nos déterminations permettent
de faire 1+1
= 3 et de mettre à l'image de ce qui a
été décidé par le Président de la
République pour l'année 2024 le sport
comme grande cause nationale au cœur de
notre modèle de société dans un moment
où il peut aussi
apporter un impact fédérateur
merci Madame la Ministre on va commencer
la première série de questions avec
Jean-Jacques Lauzat qui puis ensuite
j'ai oublié
Michel Savin en tant que président du
groupe d'études pratiques sportives et
grands événement et puis les deux
rapporteurs de la mission Jo
d'habitation Claude
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre d'abord effectivement toutes
nos félicitations parce que par-delà
votre nomination vous avez réussi à
obtenir pour le sport le retour un
ministère de plein exercice et je crois
que c'est un souhait qui avait été
exprimé par un grand nombre d'entre nous
par-delà les sensibilités politiques et
il s'agit d'une sorte de retour à une
forme de normalisation étant donné ce
phénomène de société que représente le
sport alors effectivement le président
le rappeler dans quelques jours nous
aurons l'occasion de vous auditionner
sur le budget sport de la loi de
finances de 1023 donc je passerai sous
silence le passeport la solideo ou bien
encore
la question incontournable des taxes
affectées bon je commencerai par
l'actualité internationale qui est quand
même particulièrement chargée et le
sport est aussi concerné par cette
actualité je pense notamment aux
aberrations financières et
environnementales concernant le Mondial
de football au Qatar même si
effectivement ce type de question aurait
dû se poser en 2010 au moment de
l'attribution mais je voudrais quand
même avoir votre sentiment parce que
face à ces extravagances pour ne pas
dire ces délires environnementaux et
financier il est à craindre de voir
beaucoup de personnes s'éloignées des
sports de compétition et je passe sous
silence bien sûr l'attribution des jeux
divers asiatiques à l'Arabie Saoudite
ces derniers jours maintenant ce qui
concerne la guerre en Ukraine on
préconise on présente très souvent le
sport comme étant facteur de paix entre
les différentes nations et je voudrais
savoir si selon vous en matière de
diplomatie sportive en matière de power
comme on dit vous pensez que la
communauté sportive internationale a été
véritablement ou pas à la hauteur de la
tragédie ukrainienne deuxièmement à
l'occasion des JO 2024 très souvent il
était dit ces dernières années on va
profiter de cette circonstance pour
réinventer pour ne pas dire réoxygéner
le modèle sportif français et c'est vrai
vous l'avez rappelé depuis 19 beaucoup
de choses ont été faites la NAS ça
déclinaison territoriale la loi du 2
mars dernier qui a c'est vrai réformé la
gouvernance le colloque du 18 juillet où
vous avez véritablement précisé des
choses madame la ministre notamment dans
les prérogaties des uns et des autres et
les relations entre la direction des
sports et d'autre part la NS et pourtant
malgré tout cela et bien de grandes
institutions aujourd'hui sont traversées
par tout un tas de difficultés pour ne
pas dire de dysfonctionnement CNOSF F %
de football de rugby comité
d'organisation à la coupe du monde de
rugby et je ne reviens pas sur le sport
de glace alors c'est vrai qu'il faut
relativiser parce que sur 116
fédérations sportives agréée il n'y a
qu'un petit nombre de fédérations qui
sont concernés par ces dérives mais ce
sont les plus populaires et les plus
médiatisés du ma question est-ce que
l'on doit mettre
toutes ces polémiques là sur le compte
de défaillance individuelle ou bien
faudra-t-il reprendre la réflexion et
bien sûr la question de la gouvernance
du fonctionnement des fédérations la
démocratie interne la formation des
dirigeants la transparence la
responsabilité individuelle etc y
compris peut-être à travers un nouveau
texte de loi dans ce genre de dérive
quels sont les raisons qui pourraient
amener l'État à intervenir et de quels
moyens dispose-t-il
troisième la Cour des comptes vient de
remettre au Parlement un rapport sur
l'agence nationale du sport et vous
savez que la forme juridique de ce GIP
est interrogé par la Cour des comptes
cela avait déjà été fait au tout début
par le Conseil d'État notamment en ce
qui concerne le lien entre l'État et la
ns madame la ministre avez-vous pensé de
ce rapport de la Cour des comptes
autre question et qui est confirmée
d'ailleurs par les premières auditions
budgétaires on constate une inquiétude
du mouvement sportif déjà si je peux
dire sur l'après 2024 car la loi
notamment parce que la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
concerne donc la période 2023 2027
prévoit un volume financier en
décélération à partir de 2025 et sur ces
inquiétudes je comptais simplement un
seul exemple qui porte sur les
équipements actuellement est mise en
oeuvre et c'est bien un programme
spécifique de création de 5000
équipement sportifs de proximité
jusqu'en 2024 ne pensez-vous pas que
d'ores et déjà et bien il faut envisager
de d'enchaîner cette fois-ci sur un
ambitieux programme de rénovation des
équipements sportifs locaux et
structurant quand on voit que près de
1/4 de ces équipements là ont plus de 45
ans et non jamais été modernisé alors
j'avais une question c'est à sobriété
énergétique mais vous avez répondu enfin
une question sur le plan vélo et
mobilité active qui est maintenant
lancée il complète en quelque sorte en
tout cas il se trouve dans la continuité
de la loi du 2 mars dernier qui est en
quelque sorte consacré comme savoir
sportif fondamental le savoir-faire du
vélo et je voudrais savoir quelle est la
place qu'occupera le ministère des
Sports dans ce plan vélo aux côtés
notamment du ministère des Transports et
enfin
ultime question il y a quelques jours
ont été rendus publics par l'INSEP les
chiffres concernant la chute du nombre
de pratiquants
et comme moins 15% même si tout ça c'est
très hétérogène il y a des des sports
qui gagnent des licenciés et notamment
d'équitation ou le golfe mais je
voudrais savoir si ces chiffres de moins
15% au moment où on reprend les licences
en septembre octobre est-ce que cette
tendance là selon le ministère est
aujourd'hui confirmé dans dans les faits
merci président madame la ministre merci
donc de venir de vous exprimer devant
notre commission sur les politiques que
vous souhaitez mener dans votre
ministère votre arrivée au ministère n'a
pas été de tout repos mais je tenais à
vous féliciter pour cette prise de
fonction en effet depuis votre prise de
fonction vous avez eu à gérer les
événements et des dysfonctionnements
inacceptables qui se sont déroulés au
Stade de France
on a reconnu
votre position par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé
ce jour-là à Paris ce qui n'est pas le
cas de votre collègue ministre de
l'Intérieur
actuellement Jean-Jacques lozac l'a dit
le président l'a rappelé vous faites
aussi face à des événements où le sport
fait plutôt la une dans la presse sur
les affaires judiciaires ou des faits
divers
on va pas les rappeler aussi bien au
niveau du foot que sur le rugby la
Fédération que France 2023 que des
agressions aussi de footballeuses qui se
sont déroulées des deux jeunes femmes
qui jouent en équipe de France
bien sûr la crise qui est secoue
aujourd'hui le Comité olympique et
sportif
c'est même alors j'entends bien c'est
des phénomènes qui se passent dans les
fédérations mais c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui d'image du sport en France
qui est abîmé et ça à un an de la Coupe
du monde de rugby il y a deux ans des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques c'est
pas la meilleure façon de promouvoir de
faire la promotion du sport dans notre
pays
je voudrais aussi profiter de de mon
intervention pour vous remercier madame
la ministre avant de vous poser mes
questions sur les coûts dont vous avez
fait part concernant le programme des
équipements sportifs de proximité
financier par l'Agence Nationale des
sports
le conseil d'administration en effet
validé il y a quelques jours une
proposition que j'avais évoquée lors
d'un précédent
conseil d'administration et sur lequel
nous avions pu échanger qui permet de
pouvoir ouvrir le dispositif à toutes
les collectivités alors que auparavant
une 10% d'entre elles en étaient exclues
et je trouve qu'il était regrettable que
tous les territoires ne puissent pas
accéder à ce type de financement et donc
encore une fois merci pour votre soutien
et l'implication qui a été la vôtre pour
que cette mesure puisse être validée par
le conseil d'administration j'en viens à
mes questions madame la ministre
notamment sur les questions d'actualité
Jean-Jacques Lauzac vient de le préciser
concernant l'Agence nationale du sport
et il vous a demandé votre avis sur sur
le rapport qui a été remis par la Cour
des comptes moi je voudrais avoir votre
que comptez-vous faire concrètement par
rapport aux différentes remarques et
critiques qui sont émises par le rapport
comment aussi sur l'agence nationale du
sport au commandement plus efficace et
les conférences régionales et les
conférences des financeurs aujourd'hui
pour ceux qui participent toutes ces
structures ne sont pas ou sont mal
identifiées sur nos territoires et je
pense aussi où on a déjà échangé sur ce
point qu'il faut clarifier et préciser
tout cela à quoi sert l'agence comment
les communes qu'elles soient au niveau
des communes des intercommités des
départements région peuvent se sentir
impliqués par les politiques qui sont
menées à l'échelle de ces territoires et
puis je pense qu'il y a une nécessité au
niveau de du gouvernement et du
ministère de clarifier les choses et de
donner peut-être une ligue de
perspective beaucoup plus restreinte
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a un volet
tellement large des propositions qu'en
fin de compte lorsqu'on arrive dans les
conférences des financeurs et ben on se
retrouve
sans moyens et et avec des dossiers qui
n'arrivent pas à avancer
autre autre sujet qui sur lequel on
souhaiterait avoir votre votre point de
vue même si aujourd'hui
c'est un peu difficile c'est la crise
qui secoue le Comité Olympique et
Sportif on est vraiment inquiet par
rapport à son fonctionnement et il est
important que rapidement des solutions
et des propositions soient faites pour
que
cet organisme puisse rapidement se
remettre au travail dans le cadre encore
des grands événements qui arrivent une
question un peu plus pointue madame la
ministre et pourtant c'est un sujet qui
est important alors que des dizaines de
milliers de volontaires vont être
sollicités et mobilisés pour participer
à l'organisation de Paris 2023 et pour
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 de nouveau la question de la
requalification de la leur mission
contrat de travail et soulevé nous
avions été sollicités et alerté en 2016
lors de l'Euro lorsque les contrôles de
l'URSSAF avaient requalifié ces
volontaires en contrat de travail il
serait quand même très préjudiciable
pour la la France qu'au moment des Jeux
Olympiques ce type de contrôle puisse de
nouveau avoir lieu et qu'on puisse
pointer du doigt une situation dans
lesquelles des volontaires se
retrouveraient avec une requalification
contrat de travail pour ces volontaires
qui bien sûr pour certains sont
organisés avec des orphes de départ de
journée de relations de travail mais
c'est du volontariat et c'est un sujet
sur lequel je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
des réponses à apporter pour
rassurer tout le monde enfin deux sujets
qui me tiennent à cœur la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles vous en avez
parlé et puis aussi votre tribune ce
matin est un excellent signal mais
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous allez
proposer et aussi sur un sujet qui qui a
fait débat lors du dernier
test qui a été débattu dans notre
assemblée c'est l'émergence de la
croissance d'atteinte à la laïcité dans
le milieu sportif là aussi comment
assurer que le sport demeure un espace
où la laïcité est respectée enfin
une dernière question et vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de de du sport santé vous
avez évoqué la volonté d'élargir la
prise en compte des bilans de santé mais
saurez-vous favorable à la prise en
charge de l'activité physique adaptée
par la Sécurité sociale mais là sur les
soins parce que la prise en charge du
bilan c'est bien mais lorsque les
patients qui ont des faibles ressources
doivent passer à l'acte et passer à des
des
cours de sport ou d'activité physique le
coût de c'est de ces prestations est
tellement élevées mais qu'elles font
marcher à hier donc il faut qu'on aille
beaucoup plus loin et
désespérémentations qui sont menées je
souhaiterais avoir votre avis et votre
position sur ces points là
merci de rapporteurs sur la mission Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques je ne sais
pas qui commence entre Claude Kern et
David Assouline
qui commence Claude
merci pour votre présence aujourd'hui et
je voudrais m'associer aux félicitations
des deux orateurs
précédents je vais peut-être
également dire que poser des questions
après ces deux orateurs c'est difficile
parce qu'ils ont dressé globalement le
tableau qu'on partage tous par contre
pour Paris 2024 il y a une question qui
qui me vient concerne les territoires
qui accueillent les épreuves sportives
dehors de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques parce que ces territoires
sont toujours aujourd'hui dans
l'inquiétude en effet j'ai vu j'ai
rencontré nombre d'entre eux qui
dispose déjà d'équipement et qu'on leur
demande de mettre aux normes du CIO se
pose alors la question du financement
avec aujourd'hui en filigrane
l'augmentation du coût des matériaux de
l'énergie etc
comment comptez-vous
au niveau du gouvernement répondre à la
demande d'aide de ses collectivités qui
se voient
contrainte d'augmenter souvent leur
participation financière
je vais prendre comme exemple la
Polynésie française qui pour
l'organisation du surf se voit dans
l'obligation de construire entre autres
je passe sur les autres équipements mais
une tour de contrôle pour les juges une
nouvelle tour de contrôle pour les juges
tour qui avait été estimé à un million
d'euros et qui est au final est estimé
maintenant après l'APD à 3 millions
d'euros donc il y a des financements à
trouver là dessus parce que l'héritage
peut-être réussisse si la situation
financière de nos collectivités
fortement fragilisés ne se dégrade pas
davantage
ensuite c'est une question qui a été
abordée je reviens sur la violence dans
les stades qui demeure toujours une
préoccupation préoccupante après les
débordements qui ont été observés ces
derniers mois
où on est la réflexion du Gouvernement
sur ce sujet est-ce que le projet de loi
que vous envisagez pour réconforter de
nouvelles dispositions afin de lutter
justement contre la violence dans les
stades et à leurs abords plus
précisément nous avons auditionné
récemment l'ambassadeur du Japon en
France et
concernant la sécurité des Jeux de Tokyo
il nous a indiqué que les autorités
avaient largement reconnu recourus à la
reconnaissance faciale et
il nous a fortement conseillé d'en faire
de même en France est-ce que vous seriez
prête à employer en France les
technologies qui ont fait leurs preuves
au Japon
et puis concernant la gouvernance j'en
viens également au rapport de la Cour
des comptes du mois de septembre de
cette année dans ce rapport
portant sur la NS et la nouvelle
gouvernance du sport la Cour des comptes
constate aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a ni
mutualisation des moyens ni coordination
des politiques publiques en faveur du
sport et une articulation entre le
secteur public et le secteur privé qui
stagne au niveau institutionnel comment
concrètement comptez-vous apporter des
améliorations à l'existant afin
d'atteindre enfin une gouvernance
rationalisée
et puis
ce sujet a également été abordé par
Jean-Jacques Lauzac et Michel ça va mais
j'ai été rapporteur pour la commission
de la culture lors de l'examen de la loi
du 1er août 2019 qui a donc créé cette
agence nationale du sport et à l'époque
que le Sénat avait enregistre enrichi le
texte en intégrant des dispositions
relatives à la gouvernance territoriale
en instaurant dans la loi les fameuses
conférences régionales du sport et les
conférences du financement pouvez-vous
nous dire où en est le déploiement de
ces instances et nous revient souvent
que les conférences régionales auraient
des difficultés à fonctionner compte
tenu de leur composition beaucoup trop
large et certains élus font également
état des difficultés des dragées à faire
fonctionner ces instances en tenant
suffisamment compte des besoins exprimés
par les élus locaux est-ce qu'une
évaluation
de ces dispositions étant envisagées et
puis mes autres collègues ont parlé des
problèmes de gouvernance au niveau du
CNSF et les différentes fédérations
sportives je pense qu'une grande loi
sport telle qu'elle avait quelques nous
l'attendons depuis longtemps
devrait pourraient voir le jour surtout
comme vous l'avez dit le sport et la
Grande Cause Nationale donc il faudrait
maintenant arriver au concret
merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la ministre de votre exposé
c'est vrai que
dans la chance de vous avoir eu en
premier déjà sur un sujet et deux fois
là au moment où on est déjà la tête
tournée sur le budget et donc nos
questions touchent un peu à des choses
qu'on va aussi approfondir au moment du
budget
en ce qui concerne les Jeux Olympiques
la question qui est d'actualité et qui
interpelle tout le monde
c'est comment on fait tenir le budget
alors qu'il y a une inflation
[Musique]
plutôt énorme
et qui n'est pas que conjoncturel
et donc
l'enjeu des budgets des Jeux Olympiques
a toujours été très important parce que
en général ça a été des fiasco à tel
point que de moins en moins de candidats
de ville était candidate
et puis on sait que la facture derrière
aussi il y a des dérapages trop
importants
les citoyens
commencent à moins adhérer à l'idée que
ça peut endetter des générations futures
et non pas être un élément au contraire
de cohésion et de stabilité d'un pays
alors cet enjeu est très important
je sais que vous l'avez abordé et
notamment sur la livraison des ouvrages
vous avez proposé aux collectivités
locales de financer les deux tiers et le
gouvernement est tiers
comment êtes-vous arrivé à cette
proposition
et puis globalement à ce que vous pouvez
me dire comme d'autres responsables
l'ont dit que il y a pas de sujet et que
on sera à l'équilibre et que déjà tout a
été anticipé pour faire en sorte que
cette inflation devienne pas perturbée
ce qui était prévu parce qu'il y a deux
solutions où on fait la même chose que
ce qui était prévu et ça va coûter plus
cher comme on finance ou vous avez
décidé ou vous allez décider de baisser
ce qui était prévu pour rentrer dans les
clous donc je voudrais un éclairage là
dessus sur sur comment le gouvernement
voit tout ça
le deuxième enjeu des Jeux Olympiques
pour que ça reste quelque chose
qui suscite l'adhésion des Français
parce que sans cela ça marchera pas
et on a vu que au Japon ça a bougé
la majorité était favorable
malheureusement c'est arrivé à un moment
donné où il y a eu la pandémie la
majorité s'est retourné est devenu
contre parce qu'elle a eu peur de
l'afflux
de de
personnes venant de du monde entier
permettant de de faire de se développer
la propagation du virus et ensuite par
la réussite des jeux où elle s'est
encore retournée parce que les Japonais
ont considéré que c'était bien pour eux
et que ça s'était très bien passé donc
l'opinion est tributaire aussi de
comment on fait il y a l'aspect donc
économique social
l'implication et c'est vrai que je veux
vraiment vous interroger sur le fait que
alors que les grands événements français
ce sont plutôt bien passé avec une
reconnaissance de savoir-faire de de
convivialité de fraternité la Coupe
d'Europe etc de football bon ces
derniers temps il y a inquiétude
il y a inquiétude pourquoi parce que il
y a eu Saint-Denis certes mais pas
seulement
les images qu'on a vu sur les stades et
des grands matchs de football
laissent à penser qu'il y a une maladie
française plus forte que dans d'autres
pays
et en termes parfois de racisme etc mais
en termes de violence pure
et donc
cela s'additionnant avec les affaires
qui ont été évoquées dans les
fédérations importantes parce que très
populaire Rugby Football sur
sur
l'éthique du sport
comment envisager vous maintenant sur
ces questions de taper assez fort pour
qu'on soit exemplaire et irréprochable
parce que c'est le le racisme la
violence dans les stades c'est quelque
chose de récurrent et à chaque fois on a
dit qu'on allait prendre les mesures et
maintenant ce qui sont aux manettes
disent eux-mêmes à quel moment on va
dire les choses de façon suffisamment
forte et exemplaire pour que ça ne se
reproduise plus donc il y a les
fédérations qui ont des choses à faire
mais comment le ministère compte
accompagné ça voilà les deux principales
questions que je voulais vous poser
concernant les JO permettez-moi parce
que ça sera pas dans le la discussion
sur le budget de poser une question
récurrente je vais même pas l'argumenter
tellement j'en ai assez
j'ai produit un rapport à la demande du
gouvernement en 2016 sur la diffusion en
clair des événements sportifs majeurs
puisque le gouvernement était obligé de
réviser son décret qui est relativement
caduque de 2004
j'ai perdu j'ai pas perdu du temps
c'était extraordinaire comme travail il
y avait il y a 50 auditions enfin tout
un boulot de dingue on va dire
impliquant des services de l'État qui
ont dû aussi consacrer beaucoup de temps
et quand j'ai produit le rapport il
était évident les deux ministres ont dit
on va mettre en oeuvre quasi
intégralement vos propositions car elles
sont elles sont ils ont très précises et
très juste
ce gouvernement est passé à l'époque et
puis depuis encore trois ministres des
sports 3 ou 4 ministres de la Culture et
à chaque fois je viens il dit c'est
quand que ce décret va être publié et on
me dit c'est demain
maintenant ça fait 2016 ça fait 6 ans
c'est demain parce qu'il faut se décret
et parce que il est caduc l'ancien et la
dernière fois c'était il faut l'enquête
publique et juste derrière au public
parce que c'est ensuite et on me dit pas
parce qu'il y a des désaccords parce
qu'à 95% m'a-t-on dit jusqu'à
dernièrement
mes propositions écrites de façon
précise était validée par l'ensemble des
acteurs qui considéraient que c'était
juste pourquoi je dis ça parce que c'est
important le sport en clair au moment où
c'est payant à la télé c'est d'autant
plus important à la veille des JO ou
regarder du sport à la télévision et
devenu un luxe très souvent et qu'on
attend y compris avec les JO la
promotion du sport pour tous la
féminisation le handisport tout un tas
de de défis qui se joue sur le plan
médiatique pour éduquer pour impliquer
l'ensemble des citoyens notamment dans
cette grande aventure des Jeux
Olympiques
voilà madame la ministre une première
série de questions qui va vous permettre
de rentrer plus dans le détail de
certains
points que vous avez soulevé dans votre
propos liminaire je vais vous laisser y
répondre
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président et merci à chacun de entre les
sénateurs pour leur question qui sont
riches importantes
bon peut-être un mot pour répondre
d'abord à votre question sur la loi
olympique
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une phase
vraiment de d'examen de la nécessité
d'avoir recours à un projet de loi
olympique et paralympique c'est quelque
chose que nous examinons avec l'aide de
la de la Diop c'est un texte qui à ce
stade de l'examen je pense sera
probablement nécessaire
mais nous n'avons pas encore du tout pu
déterminer le calendrier de son dépôt de
son examen tout ceci va continuer de se
construire dans les semaines à venir en
toute état de cause c'est un texte qui
se veut vraiment ramasser ramener au
plus nécessaire qu'est-ce qui s'avère
probablement nécessaire c'est des
mesures sur le plan sanitaire avec des
ajustements techniques qui doivent
notamment viser à permettre à des
médecins étrangers de pouvoir dans le
centre de santé du village des athlètes
délivrés des soins et des prescriptions
il y a également des dispositions sur
l'extension à la Polynésie française de
règles relatives au dopage
nous avons également besoin de
poursuivre la facilitation de certains
points techniques sur les travaux
d'aménagement et de simplification
administrative et le dernier point sur
la sécurité c'est cet enjeu que nous
avions évoqué ensemble dans le cadre de
vos travaux sur les leçons à tirer du
Stade de France la nécessité pour mieux
gérer les flux et pour avoir une
meilleure anticipation de l'impact sur
les flux de notamment ce qui peut se
passer en termes de perturbation dans
les transports en commun d'avoir recours
à des algorithmes anonymisés
intelligents qui permettent de faciliter
les dispositifs de vidéos protection
donc c'est vraiment ce type de
disposition qui serait contenu dans ce
projet de loi encore une fois dans
l'objectif doit être vraiment
circonscrit et tourner vers ces petits
réglages dont on sait avoir besoin pour
délivrer dans de bonnes conditions notre
organisation olympique et paralympique
s'agissant du s'agissant du Qatar c'est
évidemment une question qui va continuer
de
d'être au coeur de l'actualité dans les
dans les semaines à venir
décision prise dans un autre contexte
par la FIFA en 2010 d'être attribué
cette cet événement évidemment
aujourd'hui on le regarde avec des yeux
différents les critères avec lesquels on
prendrait certainement ces décisions
serait eux-mêmes différents et pondérés
différemment ce que je crois c'est
d'abord la nécessité d'être absolument
résolument aux côtés de notre équipe de
France qui tenant du titre et confronté
à un défi sportif de tout premier plan
et je souhaite que vraiment le lien de
la nation à cette équipe sportive reste
le plus fort possible mais au-delà de ça
d'essayer le plus possible et c'est le
sens par exemple d'échanges que j'ai pu
avoir avec l'ONG Amnesty International
très récemment de faire le plus possible
levier sur cet événement pour continuer
à pousser la cause des droits humains
pour continuer à pousser la cause des
droits écologiques vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir les initiatives que
comment
à dessiner un ensemble de fédérations
européennes le dialogue qu'elle mène
avec la FIFA autour de la création d'un
centre d'accueil des travailleurs
migrants éventuellement aussi d'un fonds
d'indemnisation de ceux de ces
travailleurs qui auraient pu être
blessés ou victime sur différents
chantiers en plus du fait que cette
Coupe du Monde est aussi l'expression
par exemple à travers notre capitaine
Raphaël
Varane et Antoine Griezmann qui avait
porté ce brassard ou Anne love comme un
message d'expression très fort
pour la lutte et la prévention vraiment
de toutes les formes de discrimination
on sait sur ce registre là ce registre
des droits humains que il y a encore
beaucoup à faire dans ce pays je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure en séance des
évolutions
positives encourageantes ont été
introduites dans la législation en 2018
puis en 2020 mais nous avons besoin que
ces engagements soient tenus qu'ils
soient suivis qu'il s'amplifient
l'instauration d'un salaire minimum qui
était le premier de la région la
suppression de la kafala ce système de
tutelles sans filiation une meilleure
protection aussi des travailleurs de
leurs droits de leur des éléments de
traduction de connaissances de leurs
droits et aussi de d'un peu plus de
maîtrise de leur destin de leur capacité
à quitter le pays changer d'entreprise
tout ceci doit s'amplifier nous sommes
dans ce cet échange avec le Qatar à la
fois en bilatérale en multilatérale au
sein de l'OIT donc vous savez qu'elle a
fait fin novembre 2021 un rapport
approfondi sur les victimes des
différents chantiers dans le Qatar qui a
pu aussi relativiser un certain nombre
de conclusions qui étaient celles du
Guardian précédemment tout ce travail
nous le conduisons nous le nous le
poursuivons avec la volonté de voilà de
porter cette cause du respect des droits
humains du respect de la condition
féminine des droits LGBT sur le plan
écologique la volonté que nous avons
d'utiliser aussi la COP 27 de Charmed
cher pour encourager le Cathare à
renforcé ses engagements sa contribution
nationale qui doit être réhaussée de
manière à sécuriser sur le moyen et le
long terme que sa trajectoire de
réduction de ses émissions de carbone
soit la plus conforme possible à
l'objectif de l'accord de Paris renforcé
avec la cop26 et Glasgow d'un
réchauffement climatique maintenu
en tout cas un moment crucial pour
l'exemplarité de nos grands événements
sportifs internationaux un moment
crucial pour les critères qui préside à
leur choix je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
le fait que la FIFA d'elle-même indique
l'impératif d'une meilleure prise en
compte des critères environnementaux
dans le choix de des implantations de
ces congrandes compétitions est
encourageant mais il faut suivre tout ça
et de la même façon j'ai envie de dire
en creux presque par différence on doit
être plus résolu que jamais à nous
relever le défi que nous avons annoncé
des jeux les plus écologiques de
l'histoire avec l'engagement de diviser
par deux nos émissions d'avoir cette
neutralité carbone qui est un engagement
qui
occupe bien entendu les chantiers de la
solideo mais aussi l'action du Kojo qui
est aussi
comment dire exprimer à travers des
engagements sur la sobriété énergétique
et le raccordement au réseau
d'électricité avec l'appui de notre
partenaire enedis évidemment dans le
prolongement de ses propos
je partage le scepticisme que a pu
générer l'annonce de ces Jeux asiatiques
divers en Arabie Saoudite avec des
budgets qui sont évidemment
considérables je crois que le moment est
venu de cet exemplarité
écologique au cœur de ses projets là et
j'étais récemment lundi matin avec la
Fédération Française de Ski qui avait pu
aussi exprimer des réactions sur ce sur
ce plan là et la nécessité pour ses
événements
d'être à l'avenir mieux penser en termes
de sobriété écologique
sur le plan de l'Ukraine de l'impact de
notre diplomatie sportive je crois que
la France est investi de manière
exemplaire depuis le début du conflit
en soutien à la ligne de conduite
qu'avec courage et fermeté avec clarté
le CIO apporter rapidement d'exclure la
Russie et la Biélorussie des épreuves
sportives sous leurs drapeaux à
l'échelle internationale tout en
essayant de trouver pour ceux
d'événements des événements qui se
jouent à titre individuel une voix pour
ses athlètes russes et biélorus
consistant à se présenter sous leur nom
sans hymne sans drapeau sous le régime
donc de la stricte neutralité j'ai le
sentiment que les ministres des sports
ont été dans l'Union européenne mais
aussi au-delà de ça avec le Canada le
Japon l'Australie les États-Unis en avec
cette déclaration des ministres en mars
de 2022 et la nécessité de continuer
aussi à suspendre les représentants de
ces deux pays des fédérations
internationales je crois que pour ce qui
est du soutien effectif au peuple
ukrainien il y a cette contribution
importante c'est 100 millions d'euros
annoncé par Thomas bar mais aussi le
Relec nous avons voulu prendre en France
à différents niveaux au niveau du Comité
national olympique au niveau de
différentes fédérations la Fédération
Française de Tennis par exemple à
travers un événement comme Roland-Garros
et un soutien de cent mille dollars qui
avait été mis mais aussi l'accueil dans
nos centres dans nos crêpes dans nos
établissements sportifs à travers les
territoires d'un petit peu moins d'une
centaine de sportifs Ukrainiens pour les
aider à se préparer dans les meilleures
conditions et aussi d'avoir un volet
plus tourné vers le sport amateur de
cette appui à l'Ukraine avec le soutien
d'hébergement dans nos clubs sportifs ou
les personnes membres de ces clubs
sportifs de famille d'enfants Ukrainiens
qui ont pu être scolarisés et dont une
licence sportive a pu être financé il
faudra qu'on continue à être plus que
jamais au soutien de l'Ukraine pour les
Jeux olympiques mais aussi pour les Jeux
paralympiques qui est une dimension sur
laquelle le comité
ukrainien
est en attente de cette de cette aide de
cette mobilisation collective pour les
pour les soutenir et on leur doit se
soutien
s'agissant de la gouvernance du sport
français je vous avais lu avec beaucoup
d'attention le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui pour moi
était au fond pas surprenant c'est des
diagnostics que j'avais pu moi-même dans
ce séminaire du 18 juillet à l'INSEP
porté et qui pour moi se cristallise au
fond à deux niveaux le premier c'est au
niveau national le fait que cette mise
en place de l'agence qui est une
évolution institutionnelle marquante
nous n'en avions pas tiré toutes les
conclusions qui s'imposaient au niveau
de la direction des sports avec du coup
parfois des recoupements de périmètre
une forme de perte de sens de la part
des agents de mon ministère sur ce qui
est attendu d'eux sur la manière dont
leur rôle dans le portage des politiques
publiques doit évoluer et j'avais donc
vraiment voulu tirer toutes les
conséquences de cette évolution de notre
organisation
en expliquant bien que de mon point de
vue notre ministère des Sports doit se
centrer sur l'impulsion politique et les
orientations stratégiques qu'elle doit
prendre sous sa responsabilité
l'ensemble de nos combats régaliens Dieu
sait qu'ils sont nombreux et décisifs
aujourd'hui ça va en parler des
violences de la lutte contre le
séparatisme
mais aussi de mener beaucoup mieux que
ça n'ait fait aujourd'hui une action
d'évaluation des politiques publiques ce
qui impose d'avoir des bandes de données
beaucoup plus nourries et mieux
analysées donc je crois que cette
clarification des rôles qui se traduit
aujourd'hui par un protocole qui
clarifie le rôle de la Direction des
Sports par rapport à celui de l'agence
la réaffirmation que notre agence
nationale des Sports est l'opérateur des
politiques publiques des politiques de
l'État et qu'elle est à cet égard à
travers son double programme ambition
bleu et impulsion sport sur des
programmes stratégique dont l'impulsion
politique et le cadrage doit être donné
par des conventions d'objectifs et de
moyens plus rien annuels rigoureuses
bien définies par une lettre de mission
adressée non seulement au président de
l'agence mais également à son directeur
général donc ce renforcement de ce que
la Cour des comptes a appelé la tutelle
de ce que moi j'appellerai plutôt les
orientations stratégiques de l'agence
sont absolument capitaux en même temps
que nous avons clarifié lors du dernier
conseil d'administration de l'Agence le
6 octobre le projet commun de cette
agence pour que ces parties prenantes
expriment mieux dans la logique que vous
avez évoquée monsieur le rapporteur du
GIP qui suppose un affectuosociétatif
qui suppose une contribution de chacun
des membres de rendre beaucoup plus
clair ce que chacun en attend et ce que
chacun concrètement va y apporter et je
l'évoquais le problème est à deux
niveaux je viens de traiter la partie
nationale de l'enjeu
des plantes territoriales la nécessité
cela a été rappelée dans plusieurs des
questions d'accélérer sur le déploiement
des conférences régionales du sport ce
qui suppose de vraiment arriver à passer
à maturité entre une étape de diagnostic
et une étape de vraiment définition des
projets sportifs territoriaux dans l'été
dans les territoires qui à son tour
emmène la mise en place des conférences
des financeurs moi j'ai fait le point
avec l'ensemble des présidents des
conférences régionales le 30 septembre
dernier la dynamique est là nous avons
dans l'Hexagone maintenant 13
conférences régionales du sport qui sont
en place outre-mer les choses aussi
accélèrent nous avons de plus en plus de
projets sportifs territoriaux qui se
créent mais encore la nécessité de ne
pas disperser là aussi vous l'avez
exprimé nos conférences régionales dans
de trop nombreuses priorités la loi du 2
mars 2022 avait prévu 13ème
d'interventions très statique qui du
haut niveau au sport à l'école c'est
probablement trop et ce que nous nous
sommes dit dans l'ensemble des travaux
menés ensemble c'est la nécessité de se
centrer sur quelques priorités bien
calibrées territoire par territoire et
même parfois la nécessité de commencer
par un projet emblématique qui sera ce
catalyseur du 1+1=3 que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure qu'on ne soit pas un peu
inhibé un peu impressionné on se
demandant par où on commence mais qu'on
choisisse une priorité qu'elle soit
celle de soutien au sport féminin du
développement du numérique pour mieux
toucher les pratiquants ou encore
qu'elle est très à une meilleure
utilisation des infrastructures des
gymnase pour voilà et pardon ou des ou
des piscines de la rénovation
énergétique de nos piscines de choisir
un thème et d'avancer et d'avoir des
résultats pour donner confiance à chacun
des acteurs autour de cette de cette
innovation institutionnelle vous le je
trouve que nous avançons que beaucoup de
clarté est en train d'être faite la Cour
des comptes à livrer des travaux utiles
nous en tirons pleinement les
conséquences de manière à ce que
l'agence est le ministère des Sports
puissent travailler de concerts à une
organisation plus plus forte du sport
français aujourd'hui dans la perspective
de nos jeux olympiques et paralympiques
où elles ont tous deux ces institutions
un rôle capital
en effet sur le programme 5000
équipement je trouve que là aussi des
progrès des pas en avant sont faits vous
avez en tête les 200 millions d'euros
d'investissement que nous avons investi
enfin nous avons mis dans ce dans ce
programme 85 millions d'euros ont déjà
pu être matérialisés pour 2000 projets à
travers les territoires nous semblant en
train de simplifier l'ingénierie de ces
projets d'essayer à travers ce qu'a
évoqué le sénateur Savin c'est-à-dire
l'allègement du critère territorial de
manière à ce qu'on est plus des
investissements seulement centrés sur
les qpv et les zones de revitalisation
rurale ou l'outre-mer mais qu'on puisse
libérer du foncier au delà tout en
gardant évidemment la volonté de doter
en priorité les zones les plus carencées
sur le plan vélo et l'implication de mon
ministère elle est totale je me réjouis
que ce plan vélo connaisse sous
l'impulsion de la première ministre de
nouveaux développements avec cette
mobilisation de 250 millions d'euros sur
la seule année 2023 avec la reconduction
du fond mobilité actif qui viendra
appuyer les infrastructures sur le champ
également de la politique industrielle
l'accompagnement à la création d'une
véritable filière qui aille de
l'assemblage au recyclage en passant par
la réparation par les services mais
aussi et c'est là que mon ministère
vient en première ligne sur l'éducation
la formation des plus jeunes vous l'avez
évoqué le savoir rouler à vélo objectif
fondamental inscrit au cœur des
enseignements fondamentaux de notre
école et là nous avons pu commencer à
faire décoller l'objectif de formation
avec enfants déjà formés aux primaires
en 2021 et nous voulons que ce chiffre
il soit porté à l'intégralité d'une
classe d'âge c'est à dire un petit peu
plus de 800 000 enfants chaque année en
rythme de croisière à partir de 2024
sans évoquer bien sûr la dimension
d'accélération avec nos jeux olympiques
et paralympiques du rayonnement de ce
plan de vélo à la fois à travers un
ensemble de voies cyclables mais
également à travers le développement des
stationnements de ces vélos pour qu'on
puisse proposer au spectateur une
expérience qui deux bout en bout soit
satisfaisante sur le plan du recours aux
mobilité douce
[Musique]
les niveaux de d'avant crise donc on est
sur une très belle dynamique et j'en
veux pour preuve aussi le succès toutes
ces dernières semaines du recours au
passport qui connaît un taux de plus 45%
par rapport à l'an dernier à la même
époque en termes de taux de prise ce qui
est là aussi très important quand on
sait que c'est dispositif bah voilà il
faut qu'il puisse être absolument
utilisé par les familles qui en ont
besoin qu'elles soient titulaires de la
location de rentrée scolaire ou
s'agissant des jeunes en situation de
handicap de la location d'éducation de
la location à l'éducation de l'enfant
handicapé ou de la
je note également que nous avons des
données au niveau européen qui montrent
que la France se situe dans une moyenne
avec parfois des écarts sur l'évaluation
de la quantité de personnes qui font peu
ou pas de sport et qui me renforcent
dans ma volonté résolu d'améliorer la
qualité des données que nous possédons
sur la pratique et les pratiquants à
travers les territoires et au niveau de
mon ministère
s'agissant peut-être des
des points relatifs
aux violences sexistes et sexuelle
malheureusement c'est une question qui
fait encore
trop souvent
la une de l'actualité nous savons que
plusieurs de nos fédérations doivent
entreprendre leur vraie révolution
culturelle sur ce plan et bien mieux
s'emparer de cet enjeu de les prévenir
de les traiter vous savez que s'agissant
de la Fédération Française de foot j'ai
diligenté un audit la lettre de mission
est partie l'équipe est constituée
commencera demain et le relais que nous
assurons au niveau de la plateforme de
signalement du ministère des Sports qui
s'appelle signal sport qui a pu déjà au
cours des dernières des derniers
semestres
récoltés plus de 800 signalements
coordonnés des mesures des enquêtes de
nature judiciaire de nature
administrative parfois de nature
disciplinaire et notamment aider à ce
que plus de 300 mesures de police
administrative soit prise dans les
territoires par les préfets pour
éloigner notamment de nos enfants des
éducateurs ou des personnes dont le
profil aurait été source de telles
traitements tout à fait inadmissible
je l'ai évoqué dans ma dans ma tribune
c'est un combat qui demeure on doit
absolument
continuer à progresser avec l'ensemble
des fédérations pour systématiser
tous les signalements faire en sorte que
cette obligation elle soit ressentie par
chacun que l'engagement collectif
souhaite irréprochable sur ce sur ce
plan et nous permettent aussi de
rappeler donc à leur responsabilité ceux
qui par le passé n'auraient pas honoré
leurs obligations de signalement j'ai
également demandé dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 un
renforcement des effectifs
départementaux qui sont dédiés à ce
combat afin qu'ils puissent utiliser
tous les moyens préventifs et répressifs
en leur possession et mener notamment au
niveau des services départementaux
Jeunesse et Sport jeunesse engagement et
sport vraiment ces enquêtes avec des
moyens appropriés le dialogue de gestion
avec
fédération délégataires doit continuer
lui aussi de progresser vous savez que
cette lutte contre les violences à
caractère sexiste et sexuel s'inscrit
aussi au cœur du contrat d'engagement
républicain et que donc nous avons cette
vigilance j'ai évoqué le foot j'évoque
également la Fédération française des
sports de glace dans lesquels nous
lançons des audits pour nous assurer que
continuellement les procédés sucent en
place au sein de nos instances sportives
progressent et soient sources de la
meilleure efficacité possible je
voudrais encore si vous me le permettez
mentionné l'initiative qu'avec ma
collègue Charlotte cobel nous mènerons
au début de l'année 2023 de consacrer
une convention à l'enfant face aux
violences dans le sport de manière à ce
que définitivement on se dise que le
sport est là pour donner confiance pour
faire rêver pour faire aider nos enfants
à s'accomplir et qui ne soit en aucun
cas qui ne puisse donner lieu à des
violences contre des petits contre des
adolescents des personnes c'est ma
conviction et je ne lâcherai rien de ce
combat que ma prédécesseur avait
elle-même embrassée avec avec courage et
efficacité
s'agissant
des autres formes de violence auxquelles
notre sport est confronté
en effet nos événements
footballistiques sont encore au niveau
professionnel à l'échelle française ou à
l'échelle européenne trop souvent
émaillée de problématiques de violence
dans les stades inacceptables qui minent
le goût la fête populaire la confiance
qu'on a dans ces événements et donc la
nécessité de continuer plus que jamais à
renforcer notre arsenal de manière très
concrète sur ce terrain là est au cœur
de mes préoccupations nous renforçons la
coordination avec mon collègue le garde
des sceaux avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur ce triomme Virade qui est
très important mais également le
renforcement de l'instance nationale du
support tourisme que je vais réunir le
21 octobre prochain de manière à ce que
nous continuions à garder un dialogue de
confiance avec les associations de
supporters et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes tout en ayant tous ensemble et
c'est le sens du
la réunion que nous avions eu à la fin
du mois de juillet tout en continuant à
travailler sur l'efficacité des
sanctions collectives contre les clubs
lorsqu'elles sont nécessaires qui
doivent continuer à mieux former mieux
équiper leurs directeur de la sécurité
mieux formés les stadiers qu'il
recrutent pour le contrôle de leur
événements la nécessité également de
progresser sur l'effectivité des
sanctions individuelles en faisant en
sorte que les clubs professionnels sont
parmi eux des interdictions commerciales
de stade en même temps que sur le sujet
des interdictions administratives de
stade là aussi nous améliorons ce régime
et son efficacité nous avons également
et c'est une des leçons que nous avons
tirées des événements du Stade de France
la nécessité de continuer à travailler
sur la billetterie nominative qu'elle
permet une meilleure
identification une meilleure traçabilité
des détenteurs de billets et le cœur le
cœur du cœur de cette bataille c'est
communication des nouvelles formes de
oliganisme ce sont des personnes qui
n'aiment ni le sport ni le football ni
les stades et donc pour laquelle
l'intransigence absolue est vraiment
indispensable
nous avons à cet égard des travaux qui
vont être alimentés par Alain Bauer et
l'étude que lui a commandé la Ligue de
foot professionnel avec des éléments de
benchmark d'analyse des régimes qu'il a
pu mener à l'échelle étrangère pour
qu'on puisse aussi travailler sur cette
meilleure
identification de ces hooligans et qu'on
puisse comme vous l'avez souligné par
ailleurs absolument éradiquer de nos
stades tous les actes d'incivilité ou
d'expression de toute forme de
discrimination ou de racisme
sans transition sur un sujet évidemment
infiniment plus plus positif
celui
de nos bénévoles celui de nos
volontaires qui non seulement sont au
cœur de notre sport amateur mais aussi
seront demain au cœur de l'organisation
de nos jeux olympiques et paralympiques
45000 volontaires attendues plus à peu
près 7000 pour les collectivités locales
dont 5000 pour la seule
ville de Paris un travail également qui
nous conduit aujourd'hui avec la dijob à
recruter un certain nombre de
volontaires en situation de handicap de
manière à travailler sur l'inclusion
sociale aussi par cette dimension là une
charte des volontaires qui est un outil
aussi important qui sera laissé en
héritage à tous les grands événements
sportifs internationaux mais la
nécessité comme vous l'avez souligné de
très bien organisé le régime dans lequel
ces bénévoles vont exercer leurs
activités leur responsabilité pour
travailler sur l'accueil
des spectateurs dans nos dans nos sites
et la fluidité notamment des de la de la
circulation ou à la fin aux abords des
stades ou à l'intérieur des sites de
compétition à la demande sur ce point du
kojob et par anticipation vous souvenez
que le ministre des comptes publics à
l'époque Olivier du soft avait écrit en
mai 2021 au directeur général de
l'URSSAF pour lister les avantages en
nature qui pourront être donnés aux
bénévoles de ces jeux sans être pour
autant assujetti à cotisations et
contribution sociale ce courrier il
avait été décliné en une instruction
plus opérationnelle qui avait été
diffusée à l'ensemble des Urssaf en
juillet dernier et à titre d'exemple
parmi les avantages exonérés le petit
uniforme qui aujourd'hui travaillait
avec le partenaire des jeux Decathlon
pour les bénévoles les avantages liés à
la nourriture prenant la forme d'un
accès à la restauration collective ou
les assurances en responsabilité civile
pour quelques exemples concrets ils se
dispositif dérogatoire il a vocation à
pouvoir s'appliquer jusqu'au lendemain
des Jeux paralympiques à l'horizon du 8
octobre 2024 donc on sera évidemment
très vigilant à ce que tout ceci puisse
se passer conformément à ses accords et
à ses engagements écrits qui ont été
pris de part et d'autre
sur
le sujet des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques toujours et la prise en
compte de cet enjeu capital de de
l'inflation
je l'ai dit on est très attaché au
respect du cadre budgétaire à cette
discipline que nous nous sommes donnés
il y a néanmoins un certain nombre de
vents contraires une inflation dont
l'impact côté solideo est aujourd'hui
évaluée à 150 millions d'euros et qui
est en cours de chiffrage côté Kojo dans
un contexte où le budget du Kojo a été
établi sur une base de 1,4% pour cette
inflation là où on sait aujourd'hui les
niveaux autour de 6% qu'elle atteint
donc pour résoudre ça pas de baguette
magique mais la nécessité de revoir un
certain nombre d'arbitrages et aussi
parfois de compenser sur le plan des
recettes pour que et c'est ça
l'important nous préservions l'équilibre
entre les dépenses et les recettes
le troisième élément d'ajustement pour
faire face à ces surcoûts à ces vents
contraires c'est aussi la mobilisation
d'une part de la réserve pour aller à
vous avez en tête que au sein du budget
du Kojo il y a une réserve pour la Léa
de 315 millions d'euros 75 315 millions
d'euros qui aura en partie besoin d'être
mobilisé pour faire face à cet impact de
l'inflation s'agissant côté solideo de
sa répartition c'est pas tout à fait
exact sur le 1/3 de tiers plus
exactement c'est exact mais pas dans le
sens qui a été mentionné tout à l'heure
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les
chiffrages sont en train d'être affinés
par la solidaire qui aboutira
complètement à son conseil
d'administration de décembre sur le
sujet mais elle est comme je le disais
de l'ordre de 150 millions d'euros et
c'est 96 millions d'euros donc plutôt
deux tiers par l'État qui serait prise
en charge et un tiers par les
collectivités avec un décompte très
précis très juste très équitable qui
repose sur leur quote-part à chacune
dans les ouvrages olympiques et
paralympiques porter ses 64 ouvrages
portés par par la solideo donc d'ores et
déjà dans le budget du ministère des
sports sur lequel je reviendrai devant
vous une contribution de 61 millions
d'euros au titre de la prise en compte
par l'état de cette dimension
d'inflation est embarquée de manière à
ce que on puisse être au rendez-vous et
que donc des arbitrages budgétaires
soient fait par ailleurs pour que nous
puissions tenir notre engagement qu'il
n'y ait pas de contribution publique
additionnelle dans le cadre de
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dont je rappelle car ça
n'est jamais assez rappelé que 97% des
financements du Kojo sont d'origine
privée et que s'agissant de la solideo
sur un budget qui est au sens le plus
large du terme de 4000 euros ne
concentre une part que de
1,570 millions d'euros pour l'ensemble
des collectivités publiques dont un
petit peu un petit peu moins un milliard
170 pour l'État
que me reste-t-il à couvrir
la reconnaissance faciale
la
reconnaissance faciale
je comprends
l'attente je comprends
peut-être encore plus marqué par
l'expérience du Stade de France
l'importance de ces enjeux et pour
autant le fait que nous nous inscrivons
aujourd'hui dans des régimes qui ne
prévoit pas sur le plan de la sécurité
c'est dispositifs nous allons pour ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure travailler
sur des algorithmes intelligents mais
anonymisés de vidéoprotection qui nous
permettront de mieux repérer les
mouvements de foule dans les transports
mais ça n'est pas sur le registre
individualisé et même ces dispositifs de
vidéos protection ce sont des choses que
nous aurons besoin de regarder sous
l'oeil vigilant de la CNIL du Conseil
d'État avant de pouvoir éventuellement
vous les proposer dans le cadre de ce
projet de loi olympique et paralympique
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
du décret
relatif aux événements d'importance
majeures le décret EIM je voudrais
vraiment prendre l'engagement
solennellement devant vous monsieur le
sénateur que ce il arrive soit un vrai
Hillary il arrive
j'ai pu m'en entretenir d'ailleurs avec
le président roccolivier Metz de l'arcom
une consultation publique vous savez a
été menée de janvier à mars 2022 sur ce
registre nous avons deux enjeux majeurs
arrivés à mieux représenter le sport
féminin et arriver aussi à mieux
représenter le sport paralympique et
tout particulièrement nos jeux
paralympiques je sais que c'est l'une
des évolutions qui sont prévues
aujourd'hui à ce texte et pardon de
l'annoncer aussi là le rendez-vous avec
ma collègue la ministre de la Culture
que je verrai précisément sur ce sujet
mardi prochain et je prends là encore
l'engagement tout à fait enfin voilà
d'avoir cette pensée pour se décrire
pour vous et la nécessité absolue
d'atterrir je crois que c'est vraiment
notre volonté à tous et nous tiendrons
cette engagement
n'hésitera pas à vous le rappeler
rapidement
oui je crois
dernière série de questions je vous
demandais aux autres d'être synthétiques
parce que le temps passe j'aurais mon
Gonnet Céline Brulin sabineg et Bernard
pialer merci et puis Elsa merci
président madame la ministre dans votre
propos illiminaire vous avez évoqué à
plusieurs reprises et avec insistance le
carré magique or pour moi sport carré
magique il fallait pas hésiter à le
servir c'est le football que ça que ça
adresse avec le fameux carré magique
dont tout le monde se rappelle en 84
intronisé par Michel Hidalgo de Michel
Platini gentil Ghana Alain Giresse et
Luis Fernandez voir
j'ingénis pour ceux qui suivent donc ma
question concernera le football nous
avons voté le 2 mars 22
la loi visant la démocratie démocratiser
le sport en France et cette loi ouvrait
la possibilité pour la Ligue
professionnelle de football de créer une
société commerciale
pour traiter les droits d'exploitation
des manifestations par exemple donc je
vous laisse savoir suite à cela
notamment dans l'article 51 il est dit
je cite les statues de la société
commerciale ainsi que leur modifications
sont approuvées par l'assemblée générale
de la fédération sportive délégataire
concernés et par le ministre chargé des
sports je voulais savoir sur ce sujet si
vous aviez quelques informations sur
l'avancée de cette structure et puis
comme l'organisation d'un nouvel appel
d'offres ne tardera pas sur les droites
télévisés du championnat de Ligue 1 de
football français avez-vous là-dessus
était saisie par la Ligue
professionnelle de football merci
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de sujets très précis d'abord
les collectivités face à l'explosion des
coups de l'énergie puisque vous le savez
les collectivités sont propriétaires de
à peu près voire même un plus de 80 % du
parc des équipements sportifs
et que leur incapacité parce qu'on en
est là aujourd'hui à pouvoir assurer les
coûts de l'énergie peut évidemment avoir
un impact à court moyen ou plus long
terme sur la pratique sportive on a vu
ça a été évoqué notamment par Michel
Savin un certain nombre un certain
nombre de piscines fermées ces derniers
temps
on peut assister à d'autres choses de
cet ordre là et le plan de sobriété
énergétique que vous évoquez
à savoir réduire de degrés la
température dans les gymnases ou d'un
degrés l'eau des piscines ne permettra
Bonnant Malan que de réaliser 7 à 10%
d'économies d'énergie et donc ça il faut
sûrement le faire je ne conteste pas
mais ça ne permettrait pas ne permettra
pas de faire face à ce tsunami de
dépenses qui arrivent sur les
collectivités donc
d'abord question un peu cash est-ce que
vous prenez la mesure de ça est-ce qu'au
gouvernement prend la mesure de ça et
est-ce que vous nous les associations
d'élus etc avons une chance de
convaincre Bercy qu'il faut absolument
réagir face à cette situation qui peut
être je le dis avec un peu de gravité
extrêmement compliqué dans les mois et
les aînés à venir parce que les
rénovations énergétiques attendues
souhaité ne pourront pas se faire si les
collectivités non pas les moyens
d'investir puis deuxième sujet lui aussi
très précis c'est la crise de
recrutement qu'on vit chez les maîtres
nageurs sauveteur qui s'est
manifesté particulièrement cet été et on
pense à nos piscines mais moi qui suis
élue d'un département maritime j'y suis
évidemment très attentive et si je peux
le dire là aussi en termes un peu cash
les interpellation que j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous adresser ce sont
traduites par des réponses qui en gros
disent
le plan d'urgence consiste à ouvrir une
réflexion je vais me permettre de vous
citer ou en tout cas de citer la réponse
que vous avez bien voulu faire à un de
mes courriers
où vous nous dites parvenir rapidement
un consensus avec les représentants des
salariés et des collectivités locales en
ouvrant au plus vite les travaux de
concertation pour prévoir une réponse
provisoire à la situation d'urgence qui
a connu l'été 2022 autant dire que là
nous n'avons absolument pas de réponse à
la crise que nous connaissons et donc
j'arrête les choses vont être un peu
moins prégnantes puisque nous ne sommes
plus en situation estivale mais c'est
précisément l'occasion de préparer les
périodes à venir et il faut absolument
qu'on puisse répondre à cette question
merci
Sabine oui merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je souhaite évoquer
avec vous la question des déplacements
des supporters des clubs de football de
notre championnat bien évidemment il
faut que ça a été dit il faut que ces
déplacements se fasse dans des parfaites
conditions de sécurité et dans le
respect de l'ordre public je souhaite à
ce titre souligner le comportement
responsable et respectueux des
supporters du Racing Club de langues de
Lens les Red Tigers qui ont pris contact
dès le mois d'août dernier avec le
préfet de région
des Hauts de France pour préparer leur
déplacement à Lille pour assister au
fameux derby Lille Lens et ça c'est
parfaitement déroulé le week-end dernier
donc à l'aune de cette parfaite
coopération entre les autorités et les
supporters ne pensez-vous pas que les
interdictions de déplacement de
supporters des clubs de foot doivent
rester l'exception je vous remercie
une question courte et précise je plais
comme beaucoup d'entre nous et je me
réjouissais de
la demi-heure d'activité physique dans
toutes les écoles or aujourd'hui depuis
la rentrée quelle évaluation a été faite
et quelle injonction est faite aux
enseignants pour réaliser cette
demi-heure de d'activité physique parce
que je fais une petite enquête mon pivot
ce qu'elle vautour de tous les
enseignants que je connais et les
parents d'élèves je rencontre
je peux dire qu'on est très très loin
d'une mise en application de cette
consigne donc je sais pas quel est votre
retour
elles achalke
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre alors j'aimerais vous poser une
question sur la reconstitution des
ligues sportives à l'échelle de l'Alsace
qui est rendue possible par la loi
Alsace qui a été votée en 2019 comme
vous le savez nous sommes nombreux très
nombreux à appeler de nos vœux cette
reconstitution les élus locaux les
parlementaires et j'associe à mon propos
mon collègue mon collègue Claude Kern et
nous nous mobilisons pour que les ligues
qui le souhaitent puissent retrouver un
périmètre alsacien plus cohérent au plus
près des territoires et qui correspond
finalement à un mode de fonctionnement
qui est plus adapté au monde sportif le
22 février dernier le président de la
République avait demandé de faciliter le
déploiement des ligues d'Alsace et
d'organiser une concertation avec les
fédérations sportives aura ce jour huit
mois après cet engagement présidentielle
trois ans après le vote de la loi Alsace
la situation n'a pas malheureusement
évolué donc devant les parlementaires de
la majorité vous êtes récemment engagé à
lancer rapidement la concertation c'est
pourquoi madame la ministre ma question
est simple pourriez-vous nous indiquer
ici au Sénat le calendrier de cette
concertation et à quelle échéance les
ligues sportives pourront à nouveau et
enfin fonctionner sur le périmètre
alsacien je vous remercie
je voudrais revenir quand même aussi sur
la dernière question sur un point qui a
soulevé Michel Sava je crois mais que
d'autres aussi aborder c'est la crise au
sein du cnessf comment
quel est votre quand vous envisagez les
choses quand vous appréciez la situation
elle n'est pas simple et qu'elle va être
la position de l'État dans les semaines
à venir sur cette question là
merci beaucoup pour pour ces questions
alors sur la sur la société commerciale
pour la Ligue de foot le ministère a
déjà approuvé les statuts de la société
commerciale ce qui avait été fait avec
le décret du 28 avril 22 donc ça cette
première étape là qui établissait les
catégories de personnes nous pouvons pas
détenir de participation au capital au
sujet des droits de vote etc ça est bien
stabilisé en revanche le volet qui est
encore en cours de travail c'est le
second degré le second décret pardon qui
lui permet la commercialisation des
droits d'exploitation et des droits
audiovisuels par la société commerciale
créée par la loi et du coup qui permet
le bon fonctionnement de cette société
créée par la LFP nous on travaille
beaucoup avec vin la brune et Arnaud
Roger sur ce décret là on a la nécessité
d'avancer plus vite les dispositions
réglementaires moi normalement j'ai bon
espoir qu'elle puisse être prise début
2023 mais elle doivent l'être vous
l'avez parfaitement en tête dans le
respect des règles de la concurrence ce
qui implique qu'on puisse avec le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
bien saisir la procédure de consultation
obligatoire de l'Autorité de la
concurrence ce qui sera fait dans les
toutes prochaines semaines j'en ai pris
l'engagement vis-à-vis des acteurs du
football professionnel
sur le plan des piscines sujets qui nous
a évidemment tous beaucoup
préoccupés beaucoup mobilisés au cours
des dernières semaines
un groupe de travail dédié que j'ai mis
en place avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés les collectivités les
représentants des élus du sport les
entreprises
les fédérations aussi qui ont montré la
situation extraordinairement hétérogène
de nos piscines aujourd'hui mais
globalement le fait que ce sont des
équipements qui sont très énergivores on
sait que 60% des piscines en France
aujourd'hui ont plus de 30 ans et elles
peuvent à l'échelle d'une commune
parfois représentée jusqu'à 10% de la
consommation énergétique de ces de ces
communes donc pas de solution unique
univoque parce que en raison de leur
génération du type d'équipement du mode
de gestion des choix d'exploitation
hétérogénéité terrible au niveau de leur
modèle économique mais un combat commun
qui est d'arriver à résoudre ce mur de
notre transition énergétique vous l'avez
évoqué une première mesure que nous
avons pensé nécessaire de prendre c'est
les économies d'énergie les économies de
chauffage qui restent le principal post
de dépenses énergétique en réduisant la
température de l'eau au plan national
d'au moins 1 degré mais pas seulement
c'est là dessus que vous m'interpellez
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autres dans le
plan d'action que nous avons mis au
point donc cet engagement de parvenir à
moduler les heures les jours les
périodes de fermeture cet hiver en
optimisant du mieux que nous pouvons les
mutualisations entre les piscines d'un
même territoire le fait aussi de
faciliter de donner plus de souplesse
aux collectivités dans l'organisation
des vidanges annuels en lien avec les
agences régionales de santé vous savez
que c'est un poste de dépenses qui est
très important
l'accompagnement aussi des gestionnaires
sur les aides existantes avec les
certificats d'économie d'énergie la
nécessité comme ça a été fait par
plusieurs collectivités je pense
notamment à la mairie de Versailles de
faire bénéficier les gestionnaires des
tarifs parfois négociés de manière plus
avantageuse par les collectivités quand
cela est possible et bien évidemment
tout ceci s'inscrit aussi en complément
de l'initiative qui a été prise avec
l'article 14 de la loi de finances
rectificative d'avoir une aide pour les
communes de petites tailles confrontées
à ces dépenses cette augmentation très
forte de leur coûts énergétique plus le
fond vert se fond vert ou il y aura
jusqu'à 2 milliards d'euros mobilisés
pour accompagner les collectivités dans
tous leurs travaux de rénovation
thermique de rénovation énergétique et
on sait pour le suivre bien et c'est un
sujet que le sénateur s'avain connaît
bien au niveau de l'Agence nationale du
sport une partie importante des crédits
qui sont fléchés sur la rénovation
énergétique de nos piscines qui est un
enjeu absolument majeur donc on
continuera on sait que dans le cadre de
la ns 30 piscine ont déjà obtenu de
telles financements dans le cadre des
travaux de rénovation énergétique pour
un taux moyen de réduction quand c'est
mis en place de l'ordre de 40 %. donc il
va falloir qu'on poursuive ce plan
toujours dans cette alignement des
volontés et qu'on touche à la fois à ce
qu'on peut faire pour baisser les
consommations baisser les coûts et
arriver en même temps à avoir une
transformation structurelle de notre
parc de piscine à l'échelle du à
l'échelle à l'échelle nationale
sur le sujet
que je vais lier les connexes de nos
maîtres de nos maîtres nageurs
sauveteurs et des pénuries sur ces sur
ces métiers
je me souviens de la précision de votre
courrier j'avais essayé en effet d'y
apporter une réponse précise tout en
annonçant ce plan d'urgence et je me
suis assurée auprès de la collaboratrice
qui au sein de mon cabinet suit cette
question que ce groupe de travail est
bien aujourd'hui actif pour essayer de
trouver des solutions qui nous
permettront d'apporter et pas trop tard
des réponses satisfaisantes à cette
pénurie sur notre profil au niveau des
des maîtres nageurs sauveteurs d'ores et
déjà vous avez en tête les initiatives
qu'on a prises avec le fait que depuis
2022 on a trois autres diplômes qui
donnent le titre de M&S tout ce qui est
l'unité d'enseignement sauvetage
secourisme en milieu aquatique tout ce
qui est le djeps triathlon et aussi le
certificat de spécialisation sur le
sauvetage et le secourisme en milieu
aquatique on a également des éléments de
souplesse qui nous sont donnés au niveau
des BNSSA qui peuvent avoir une
dérogation pour la surveillance en
autonomie mais encore une fois avec des
éléments de démarche administratives qui
aujourd'hui sont trop compliquées sont
trop longs et c'est précisément l'objet
de ce groupe de travail de travailler à
cette simplification sur laquelle je
m'engage en aujourd'hui 7000 diplômes de
BNSSA qui sont délivrés chaque année et
il faut que on puisse avec l'ensemble
des organisations professionnelles de
mns les représentants aussi des
employeurs arriver à beaucoup mieux
chiffrer les besoins et avoir un vrai
plan pour cette filière qui a été je
pense un peu délaissé au cours des
dernières années
sur le sujet des déplacements des
supporters qui est à la fois un sujet de
portée
écologique lié évidemment à l'empreinte
carbone liée au mode de déplacement de
ces de ces supporters vous savez que
dans le cadre donc du plan de sobriété
énergétique que nous acterons demain
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du sport
nous cherchons vraiment à développer les
formules comme le covoiturage donné
aussi un avantage tarifaire sur les
compétitions sportives aux personnes au
spectateur qui auraient fait l'effort
d'y venir en transport en commun on va
également créer avec les acteurs du
sport professionnel un groupe de travail
pour travailler sur leur propre
condition de transport plus vers moins
carbonée donc tout ceci on le mène
évidemment avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
détermination
mais je
reconnaît aussi tout à fait l'importance
sur le plan des régimes mis en place par
les préfets autour de nos grandes
compétitions de continuer à bien
travailler avec les associations de
supporters sur le régime des
interdictions de déplacement qui sont
bien souvent frustrantes pour les
intéresser privant de compétition et de
trouver les formules qui par
anticipation et par ce dialogue restauré
notamment dans le cas de l'instance
nationale du supporterisme ou l'avantage
que nous avons et ces associations de
supporters sont très bien représentés
très engagés et très active pour créer
vraiment la confiance qui nous aidera à
stabiliser ces différents régimes
sur la problématique des 30 minutes à
l'école
donc cette généralisation qui concerne
le coeur de nos écoles élémentaires nos
35000 écoles élémentaires elle se passe
dans des conditions
satisfaisantes certaines sont équipées
d'un certain nombre de matériels les
professeurs des écoles que je voudrais
vraiment remercier pour leur
mobilisation
sont à pieds d'oeuvre pour créer cet
espace des 30 minutes parfois de manière
fractionnée parfois sur une pause
méridienne ils le font avec beaucoup de
pédagogie avec beaucoup de d'engagements
ce que moi je voudrais faire pour
rejoindre votre préoccupation c'est que
le déploiement sur l'ensemble des
territoires soit davantage incarnés là
aussi dans notre France des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques par des
grands sportifs
qui viendrait dans les cours des écoles
faire parfois un petit peu de ces 30
minutes avec nos enfants leur donner
cette habitude dont on sait qu'il est
bon pour leur santé dont on sait qu'il
est bon aussi pour leur capacités
cognitives et leur concentration un
article du Monde sur une tranche d'âge
un petit peu plus basse ce matin
montrait encore la richesse des études
menées qui démontre cet impact positif
sur nos enfants de la pratique d'une
activité physique quotidienne tout à
fait instaurer dans dans le cœur de dans
le coeur de l'école donc nous
reviendrons là-dessus avec des
initiatives mais je crois que on peut se
féliciter que ce mouvement qui avait été
engagé par 7000 établissements
volontaires il se diffuse et qu'il
permet de progressivement à nos 6,5
millions d'enfants en France d'avoir ce
moment pour se défouler se dépenser et
prendre l'habitude du sport le plus
jeune possible
sur le sujet des des ligues alsaciennes
là nous avons en effet eu une série
d'échanges récents avec les
parlementaires avec les fédérations
sportives de son particulièrement
concernés par cette volonté d'une
meilleure reconnaissance de l'identité
alsacienne le foot et le tennis qui sont
d'ailleurs dans deux situations un petit
peu différentes nous avons une
Fédération de tennis dans lequel il n'y
a pas de fusion des comités du Haut-Rhin
et du Bas-Rhin et une appartenance donc
à la Ligue du Grand est là où dans le
foot cette fusion à d'ores et déjà été
opérée dans le cadre du coût d'un
district qui relève plus largement de
cette ligue Grand-Est donc moi j'ai dit
volonté d'aider les parties prenantes
c'est d'ailleurs un engagement qui avait
pris le président de la République de
favoriser cette concertation de manière
à ce qu'on puisse mieux reconnaître
l'identité les particularismes alsaciens
aussi travailler sur la qualité de la
vie quotidienne des bénévoles des
sportifs amateurs alsaciens qui parfois
ont des distances trop longues à faire
jusqu'à l'autre bout de la région pour
participer à des compétitions et donc de
développer tout ce qu'on peut faire au
niveau de la densité des compétitions
d'un championnat d'Alsace de coupe
d'Alsace pour faciliter et réduire les
trajets
au-delà de ça
la symbolique que je connais que je
reconnais de ce mot de Ligue d'Alsace
mais que nous devons aussi concilier
avec la préoccupation qui est la mienne
que toute cette volonté de mieux
reconnaître l'identité alsacienne ne se
fasse pas dans une dynamique un peu
dangereuse à mes yeux de démembrement
territorial nous aurons le moment venu
les discussions qui s'imposeront entre
le Parlement le gouvernement sur la loi
notre mais pour l'instant on s'inscrit
dans ce cadre-là et c'est pourquoi il
est particulièrement important à mes
yeux de rappeler que la loi du 2 août
2019 qui crée la collectivité européenne
d'Alsace
autorise bien les fédérations sportives
d'ailleurs ou culturelles à créer des
organes de type infras régionaux à
l'échelle de l'Alsace donc c'est
vraiment avec l'ensemble de ces
considérations que je vais honorer
l'engagement que j'ai pris de d'animer
cette concertation
prenez que compte tenu de l'ensemble des
actualités récentes dans le foot je n'ai
pas pu prioriser ça sur d'autres
éléments dans les toutes dernières
semaines mais cet engagement j'en ai
reparlé avec le président de la ligue
de du Grand Est de foot et également
avec les dirigeants de la Fédération
française de tennis et chacune des
parties est engagée pour que cette
concertation est bel et bien lieu dans
un calendrier tout à fait rapproché et
j'en prends ici l'engagement devant vous
madame la sénatrice
sur le dernier point qui est celui de la
crise du CNOSF c'est évidemment et donc
décidément un moment pas facile pour le
sport français
nous avons évoqué le foot nous aurions
pu évoquer le rugby et la fin du contrat
de du directeur général du GIP Claudette
sont remplacement par Julien Colette
pour retrouver un climat social plus
apaisé
le CNOSF je crois que on est dans un
moment très important nous avons la
présidente Brigitte Enrique
dont je veux penser à l'état de santé
elle doit prendre le temps de récupérer
toutes ces forces elle est aujourd'hui
entourée d'une équipe
solide légitime et respectée autour
d'elle avec un Jean-Pierre sulta avec
une nouvelle secrétaire général en la
personne d'Astrid Guyard une athlète de
tout premier plan très reconnu par ses
pairs et par la communauté sportive par
Michel Callot le trésorier et président
de la Fédération française de cyclisme
et également Sébastien Poirier le
président de la de la Fédération
[Musique]
sport mécanique qui représente le monde
non olympique au sein de ce CNOSF donc
il y a cette collégialité qui est
renforcée
il y aura demain à l'initiative d'une ou
deux personnes un débat aussi sur
l'avenir du CNOSF mais j'ai coutume de
dire que
l'avenir du CNOSF il est d'abord et
avant tout dans la livraison des jeux et
donc dans la nécessité de se rassembler
de se concentrer sur le travail qui est
à effectuer pour les jeunes notamment le
Club France de la Villette la bonne
marche de la préparation de nos athlètes
en synergie avec l'Agence nationale du
sport et toutes nos fédérations et aussi
la concentration sur les décisions que
dans le cas du comité de pilotage qui
s'appelle gagné en France nous devons
prendre pour toute la bonne organisation
de la préparation de nos athlètes des
staffs des encadrants parfois aussi de
leurs proches de leur famille des
accrédités en synergie aussi avec la
problématique des centres de préparation
au jeu qui accueilleront des délégations
étrangères qui viendront se préparer un
petit peu à l'avance sur le territoire
national j'ai échangé sur tout ça avec
le CIO qui partage complètement ce
triple message de d'abord prendre soin
des personnes et les laisser leur donner
le temps et leur laisser le la capacité
de récupérer
une volonté absolue de rassemblement et
une volonté de concentration pour être
au rendez-vous de ce défi historique de
nos jeux olympiques et paralympiques la
France attend beaucoup de nous le CNOSF
a un travail important à mener il faut
que ce maillon soit un maillon fort de
notre équation de préparation au jeu
merci mesdames ministres pour la
précision que vous avez apporté à
chacune de nos questions et le temps que
vous nous avez consacré je crois que cet
échange était important puisque nous
n'avons pas eu l'occasion de la voir
jusqu'à présent et mais pour nous il
était extrêmement important de vous
entendre ou rentrer dans le comme ça le
détail d'un certain à la fois de sujet
mais aussi des grands axes de la
politique que vous souhaitez mener et
puis bien sûr on va continuer cet
échange le 2 novembre cette fois-ci en
rentrant plus dans la dimension
budgétaire à travers les l'analyse des
crédits du PLF 2023 et le rapporteur
mais chacun des sénateurs intéressé la
question sportive ne manquera pas de
vous interroger sur la dimension
financière cette fois-ci d'un certain
nombre de points que vous avez présenté
ce soir merci Madame la Ministre merci
infiniment et juste une toute petite
bonne nouvelle la confirmation des
financements pour la Polynésie les coûts
sur la tour contrôle pour les juges
seront bien prises en charge par 2024 et
également le soutien de la NS et
confirmé donc je voulais terminer aussi
par cette petite précision quand même